my name is zoe dingaman
[Music]
i play football for notre dame
robotic football
[Music]
[Music]
at the university of notre dame
football is a big deal
in the basement halls of the engineering
school a group of students are turning
their beloved sport
into
[Music]
science the robotic football club is a
engineering club with students from a
variety of different engineering majors
that work together to design build
fabricate and play with robots
you may not think it but robotic
football actually is a lot like real
football our goal in this club is to
make the game as comparable to human
football as possible
we have for example a quarterback that
can throw a ball we have wide receivers
that can catch the ball we have
offensive lineman defensive lineman
offensive lineman on the kickoff st
connor michelle i want you hitting
people on the kickoff robotic football
is definitely a contact sport you're
trying to hit the other team's robots as
hard as you can
and so you need to build designs that
are robust that can handle that sort of
stress that they're constantly placed
under
[Music]
from its founding six years ago the
club's roster now boasts 20 robot
football players at a variety of
positions all controlled and driven by
35 humans on the sideline
this is rpm it's our first string
quarterback and it's a really
interesting robot it uses
semi-autonomous features
to scan the field and find the receiver
that i'd like to pass to once it does
that it can look at the size of the
receiver and know how far it should
throw the ball to it
this is terabyte and it's our running
back it's really great at finding the
gap to go down the field and get a
touchdown
iris chocolate is one of our linebackers
and it makes a lot of really great open
field tackles
this is justin unit and it's our kicker
it can accurately kick the ball between
2 and 60 feet this is one of the most
precise robots on our team
[Music]
notre dame competes against three other
midwest colleges in a tournament held
each spring
but it takes a full school year to
prepare for that gauntlet in the fall
semester the team recruits new members
and trains them for a one-off scrimmage
with another college's team this year
their fall opponent is valparaiso
university and they're not leaving
anything to chance
in the week before the game they're
running practice drills they're learning
the playbook and they're watching tape
just like any other football team this
is basically the the culmination of all
this work you've put in in the shop with
these robots building them repairing
them designing them and you're going out
and basically watching your engineering
put to the test
irish on three one two three irish
[Applause]
[Music]
the rules of robotic football are very
similar to that of human football so we
follow ncaa rules to the best of our
ability there are two 20-minute halves
for a game with a 10-minute half-time so
it's a very quick paced game
there we go these robots take a lot of
big hits
[Music]
we have a backup for every robot just in
case one breaks down
so if the quarterback breaks down then
we pull it off and put the second string
one in and the pit crew will work on it
and try and fix it as quickly as
possible
[Applause]
with their starting quarterback back in
the game after a quick medical break the
robotic irish fight to hold their narrow
lead but can't score
a touchdown and an extra point will
snatch victory from notre dame
this is the game
get it get it
[Applause]
the goal of this is to grow it to be a
truly national competition where we can
have multiple conferences competing for
the trophy
one day
this could be a real sport or maybe it
already is
this is basically real football it's
just not humans playing it
[Music]
you